foreign
AJ's kicking us off in San Diego AJ
welcome to the show
hey George hey Ken thanks for taking my
call sure how can we help
so um I've got a career question
um I I want to know how to plan for the
future here I'm very very fortunate
financially but my concern is around the
culture in my in my company I work for a
small investment brokerage not many
people run heavily from the top down and
if it was just a on a financial basis I
would stay here forever I like what I do
I like building relationships and sales
but like I say it's just kind of the
culture that you know has me concerned
from a principal standpoint what
specifically or what are you comfortable
sharing as it relates to this culture
stuff that's wanting you to driving you
crazy making you want to leave
uh it's coming from the top down and so
in this in this role it's uh you know
commission-based job with preset you
know
um percentages or commissions if you
will and
um I think because for a small group and
and just the dynamic of it my managing
broker uh will you know dip his hand
into the pot and okay I want you to be
more specific so AJ you're saying you
don't agree with the com structure and
you feel like your boss is stealing from
you
yeah the calm structure is very clear
but the comp structure is not followed
I can give you an example that's what
I'm looking for give me an example
perfect so this will happen one every
four or five deals
um where uh so we did a deal just
recently to close that
um
you know the total Commission on the
deal is 70 000 uh give or take my comp
on the deal
um based on our contract is 35
000 I end up with 20.
so you're supposed to get 50 of any
Commission
right yeah well what was the reason
given was there any reason given for why
you took a fifteen thousand dollar hit
on a on a commission that is laid out
clearly in your employment agreement
yeah the reason is the same as it always
is I'm I'm good to you I give you the
opportunity
and
um you know so I'm I'm just not changing
it okay so what's your question because
I'm ready to rip this leader of yours as
this This Disaster this this bad boss
this this is this is manipulation it's
it's horrible oh I couldn't hold it in
George what was your question
yeah I know what it is from a
psychological standpoint
um the reason I'm still holding on is
because at the end of the day
I still do really well here and you know
I wonder am I gonna I feel like I'm
winning a lottery ticket as far as
income and am I going to get that
somewhere else okay so what do you sell
real estate okay bro
um first of all if you're good at
selling real estate you can sell real
estate for anybody anywhere anytime but
this is eating away at you
and it should for sure I know and listen
it's not going to get better
I'm gonna call you out on something
because I'm your friend
I think you're scared I think you're
scared to leave because I think you'll
you don't believe you can do what you're
doing anywhere else I think that's
pretty apparent and so I think you got
some fear maybe some doubt and I think
that's what's keeping you there but let
me tell you something you either
overcome this fear and doubt and leave
or
you're going to become so resentful so
bitter and something bad is going to
happen as opposed to you taking control
of your life and not be treated this way
that's a great point I know
so AJ I only see two options here either
you leave or you deal with it and go hey
I'm going to set up a meeting with
another leader bring them into it and
say Here's what's going on I need a
solution for this
can you do that is there another leader
that you can involve
no it's it's such a small team there's
there's six of us and I'm you know so is
that person basically the CEO are they
running the company
yeah yeah it's manipulation it's over
the today was the day we decided now
we're gonna go find another broker
or another firm or whatever and you're
gonna relationship yourself into this
okay your head's gonna be high
shoulders back
and you're gonna be bold because you
know you can sell so go right go where
you're treated properly
you have not hit the lottery at all in
fact the next job where you actually get
paid your full commission that might
feel like you hit the lottery but right
now you're you're being manipulated
it's true I mean that you know the one
caveat being is
comes in and he he does you know hand it
out right it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter you feel like a victim right now
you're like a dog that's been hit its
whole life
and every time every time he hits you
every time you hit that dog it's like
the dog going well he does feed me
consistently brings a lot of food home
who cares man every time he takes from
your commission that is rightfully yours
based on the agreement that he made or
she made with you it is absolutely
manipulating you and it is destructive
and you have bought the narrative you've
bought the lie because you don't think
you can go to us this listen this is
done
there's nothing there's no more caveats
mm-hmm and so from a career perspective
um I don't you know I almost feel like
I I like the business I want to I want
to go off someday and do it myself I
want to be you know the managing broker
of my own business so do I do I stick
out until I feel ready to do that I feel
like no they'll never be ready my man no
just gotta start
would you would you tell someone to stay
in a place where they're just being
abused
no no don't stay stay in the business
but go work for somebody else and then
when we make this next move here's what
I want you focusing on what do I need to
learn that I don't know now that will
set me up and put me in a place where I
could work for myself and we're gonna go
get that experience go get that
knowledge do you understand
yeah it's awesome that's what I've been
thinking about do it stop thinking
awesome thanks guys all right you got it
man man that lack of Integrity we're not
moving past that it's time it's not
gonna change